[Music]
thank you
this is Sky News at 10 our top story the
effort to escape from conflict towards
Sudan our team in the port city where
thousands are trying to get out
this is madness the numbers are
overwhelming people here from all over
the world wanting to get out of Sudan as
soon as possible but struggling to find
a sustainable way to do so
the window for evacuation is closing
warns the British government as it says
its rescue flights will end tomorrow
also tonight
defiant but divided why the Health
Service unions look set to agree to the
latest payoffer despite high-profile
holdouts like the RCN
[Music]
a sharp exit for the BBC's chair
resigning after his founder not to have
revealed the potential conflict of
interest involving Boris Johnson
the big freeze threatening a big melt we
report from California where climate
change driven extreme weather is causing
fears of flooding
and the king and queen consort preparing
for the coronation the new official
photos released tonight
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening the window for British
passport holders to escape Sudan is
closing tonight the government says
flights will end by early evening
tomorrow inside Sudan we saw the
desperation of many trying to get out by
boat today in the country's main Port
City
or people have attempted to escape the
conflict in Sudan by land air and sea
much of the evacuation Focus has been at
Wadi sayidna Airfield north of Khartoum
the British evacuation Mission has
rescued
1573 people largely from the Airfield
many more people though have fled
Overland with up to 20 000 people having
entered Chad alone and Port Sudan has
become a focus for foreign Nationals
hoping to escape the Violence by sea
with passenger ships making Crossings to
Jeddah in Saudi Arabia our Africa
correspondent usra El bagira traveled
the opposite way today along with some
Sudanese people trying to get home
despite the violence this is what she
saw as she traveled to Port Sudan
ships have been carrying people to
safety from Sudan but this one is taking
them to its Shores
swathes of Sudanese people took the
first travel option back to their
country to be with their loved ones
death will find you anywhere he says
it's important we're with our families
I have been one of the loser of this
award Ashraf is a Saudi Arabia resident
but lost his mother and sister in the
early days of the war they died in a car
accident as they fled the violence they
need to go there to support my sister my
brother because because of this
they are really in bad situation
Mona was making a pilgrimage to Makkah
when Hell broke loose back home
um suffering a lot
until I found a jacket
yeah because I left my child one year
and a half
you know
people flood the deck anxiously waiting
to disembark
we were offered amnesty but insist on
reaching Sudan no matter what he says
[Music]
but they're yet to see what Sudan has
become
Port sedan has transformed into an
epicenter of displacement
hundreds are here praying they'll win
the lottery and their names will be
called
the weight already feels too long this
is madness the numbers are overwhelming
people here from all over the world
wanting to get out of Sudan as soon as
possible but struggling to find a
sustainable way to do so there have been
many promises that haven't been
fulfilled there have been many ships
that have come and gone
we are suffering she says even in Syria
we didn't see War like this
your Sudanese your husband's from Yemen
where are you going to go
actually I'm going to foreign you're
going to go to Yemen yeah you prefer
Yemen to Sudan right now yeah yeah why
you see now there is no safety
masses of people who would choose
anything else than the horror from which
they've come
Sky News Sudan
the Deputy Prime Minister said today
that the rescue flights taking British
Nationals out of Sudan would end
tomorrow because of a fall in the number
of people asking to board them Oliver
Darwin said Consular support would be
provided in the country for those who
remain
what we have seen over the past 24 hours
or so is a significant decline in the
British Nationals coming forward now
that's what you'd expect it's what's
happened with other countries so what we
are saying now is that people should
expect within the next 24 hours so by
six o'clock UK time tomorrow for us to
cease those flights
foreign
politics correspondent Nick Martin is at
the foreign office tonight uh Nick the
chance for British passport holders to
get out of Sudan with government help is
nearly over but what happens after 6 p.m
tomorrow UK time
well it becomes a very complicated
picture is the short answer Oliver
dowdon tonight saying that because
demand had appeared to have dropped for
those evacuation flights they decided to
impose this very tight 24-hour window by
which time people must get to that
Airfield by 6 PM UK time tomorrow
otherwise there will be no more British
evacuation flights of course the picture
is far more complicated than that the
truth is the Airfield that they've been
using has been falling apart for the
last few days the runway is so brittle
that those heavy planes landing on it
have started to break it up that cannot
continue but also just because the
ceasefire a fragile one has been
extended for another three days the
British know that that cannot be relied
upon and that the position at that
airport in planes landing and it becomes
more perilous as the days go on so what
do people do when those planes stop
taking off they must go to to Port Sudan
but the advice is vague from the foreign
office they say that after tomorrow
there will be some Consular help up
there they don't say any more than that
the truth is that for British passport
holders and their eligible dependents
that's children mainly they have to head
up there and cross their fingers that
they'll be able to get on a boat out
there is a naval presence up there HMS
Lancaster that's a frigate no one's
getting on that so after tomorrow the
only chances through Port Sudan or a
land border and after that choices and
opportunities to get out of this very
dangerous place will diminish very
quickly
here for that update
the strikes in the NHS have been running
for more than four months but there is
just a glimmer of hope tonight that they
could be coming to an end after the GMB
Union voted to accept the government's
pay deal it means that unions
representing more than half of the
health workers involved want to take it
that may mean the government imposes the
deal despite high-profile dissenters
like the Royal College of Nursing as our
health correspondent ashes Joshua
reports a pivotal moment in a dispute
that has divided the NHS
56 of GMB members have voted to accept
the pay offer it's a result that means
the majority of NHS staff Council unions
have provisionally agreed to a five
percent pay increase and the lump sum
payments offered by the government for
GMB the current dispute over last year's
pay is now over it means our members can
return to work and we will be urging the
government that if this vote is carried
at the staff Council next week the
arrangements are made to immediately pay
that money to get that money into our
members pockets
but the offer has left unions divided
while Unison and GMB now want the deal
implemented RCN and unite have rejected
it and say they will continue to strike
that will not stop us taking action to
win a fair deal for our members but this
is also about the future of the NHS
itself 133
000 vacancies in England alone this pay
deal goes nowhere near to dealing uh
with that Great Ormond Street Children's
Hospital has warned a walk out by nurses
that starts on Sunday has left them with
difficult decisions about the care they
can provide
Saint Thomas's Hospital in central
London has warned its a e service will
also be significantly reduced critical
care nurse Dave Carr will be among those
on the picket line I think we'll
obviously have to discuss what we do but
what I'd like to see is I'd like to see
my union unite combined with the doctors
Union the BMA and the nurses Union the
RCN and take Joint action Health
secretary Steve Barkley welcomed gmb's
announcements and says he's hopeful
other unions will now formally accept
the payoffer the NHS staff Council will
meet on Tuesday it uses an electoral
system and this GMB result means that
the number of unions who want to see the
government's payoffer implemented is now
in the majority but this won't see an
end to the strikes
unite and the RCN say they will continue
to fight with the impact of any possible
action they take will not be the same as
earlier strikes and that will be a
relief for thousands of waiting patients
Joshi Sky News in central London
meanwhile England's largest teaching
Union the National Education Union has
told the government it will ballot its
members over further strike action this
Autumn the Neu is the only Union that
currently has a mandate for industrial
action and is planning another strike on
Tuesday but it intends to coordinate
more counts with three other unions
including the National Association of
head teachers which could see up to four
hundred thousand teachers go on strike
at the same time affecting every state
school in England
Boris Johnson may have been out of
Downing Street since September but his
legacy claimed another victim today I'm
the chair of the BBC Richard Sharp
resigned the man responsible for
overseeing the BBC's Independence was
only appointed two years ago and quit
after an official report found that he
had failed to disclose potential
perceived conflicts of interest to the
panel which interviewed candidates and
advised ministers that potential
conflict of interest was helped he
provided to Boris Johnson to secure a
loan in his resignation statement Mr
Sharp insisted that his breach of the
rules was inadvertent and not material
but was resigning in the interests of
the BBC
in response the BBC board said he had
been a very effective chairman our
political correspondent Joe Pike reports
after three months of damaging headlines
and refusals to quit are you in record
today Richard Sharp bowed to the
inevitable
I have decided that it is right to
prioritize the interest of the BBC
I feel that this matter May well be a
distraction from the corporation's good
work were I to remain in post until the
end of my term even before the damning
report was published he jumped whilst
attempting to minimize his mistakes
while I did breach the governance code
for public appointments the breach does
not necessarily invalidate an
appointment
indeed I've always maintained the breach
was inadvertent
the corporation's chairman leads the BBC
board which sets its strategic Direction
budget and appoints the director General
good morning Miss Johnson so Mr Sharp
help
Saga Boris Johnson's finances or the
lack of them and Mr Sharp's role
facilitating an 800 000 pound loan did
you offer anything to Mr Sharp in
exchange for your loan sport a fact he
didn't mention when applying to bbbc
Chairman an appointment Boris Johnson
supported
among the key findings from Adam hepp
install KC were that Richard Sharp
failed to disclose potential perceived
conflicts of interest to the panel which
interviewed candidates and advised
ministers there is a risk of a
perception that Mr Sharp was recommended
for appointment because he assisted the
former prime minister in a private
Financial matter and all that he
influenced the former pm to recommend
him for the job and both these
non-disclosures caused a breach of the
governor's code
visiting Glasgow Rishi sunak again faced
questions about the actions of his
former Boston government Boris Johnson
thank you everyone and his former boss
at Goldman Sachs Richard Sharp why
didn't you sack a month ago this is
about doing things properly and
professionally and when concerns are
raised it's right that there is a proper
process an independent process should
his replacement be a non-political
appointment and are you sick and tired
of clearing up Boris Johnson's mess you
know what I'm doing is focus on
delivering for the British people good
morning to you just weeks after Gary
lineker sparked a different BBC crisis
by tweeting about politics today the
presenter waded into this round to argue
the BBC chairman should not be selected
by the government of the day all this
does revolve around the Judgment of a
former prime minister but also that of
the current top civil servant cabinet
secretary Simon case it is he who
Richard Sharp approached about financial
support for Boris Johnson this is the
same Simon K to allegedly explored
getting a private donor to pay for
refurbishments to the Downing Street
flat who recused himself from authoring
a partygate report because he'd attended
a drinks event here during the pandemic
and who may have been aware of
allegations concerning Dominic Robb and
Nadeem zahawi before they were appointed
to Rishi sunak's cabinet both have since
resigned
the search for Richard Sharp's successor
now begins but as the government appoint
the selection panel the job remains in
their gift Joe Pike Sky News
Kev hadn't suffered an aerial assault
for nearly two months but Ukraine's
Capital was targeted by Russia last
night along with other major cities at
least 19 people were killed blasts were
heard in the towns of Oman kremenchuk
baltava and mikolayev in what Russia
described as high Precision strikes more
than a dozen cruise missiles were fired
at Kiev our International correspondent
Alex Rossi reports
most people were asleep when Russia
Unleashed its wave of cruise missiles
this apartment Block in uman in central
Ukraine devastated in the attack
Moscow claims it does not Target
civilians but this is the reality
please
as morning broke firefighters continued
to search for survivors those that did
Escape traumatized
foreign
a mother and her two-year-old daughter
were killed in the bombardments
[Music]
the capital also did not Escape
unscathed although its defense systems
did manage to down most of the missiles
this apartment block was hit by debris
as they were intercepted
and despite the threats in a show of
solidarity EU leaders continued with a
visit to the city to meet President
Vladimir zelensky
the fighting in the east of the country
remains intense with Russian forces
continuing their assault but Ukraine is
expected to launch a counter-offensive
in the coming weeks
for civilians the pain of this war is
unending in Oman they're continuing to
recover bodies with the threat of more
attacks ever present
Alex Rossi Sky News
a body found by police investigating the
murder of a pregnant teacher Morel
sturrick has been formally identified as
that of her partner David Yates
police Scotland launched a hunt for
Misty Yates after Miss Doric was found
dead in Glasgow on Tuesday Yates was
wanted in connection with his partner's
murder and the police say his death is
not being treated as suspicious
a far-right extremist who set off
explosives in his own Kitchen in Walsall
in the West Midlands has been convicted
of terrorism offenses twenty-year-old
Vaughn dolphin who also built a crude
gun in his garden shed and said
minorities should be shot was found
guilty of explosives and Firearms
offenses as well
the Florida governor Ron DeSantis has
held a meeting with the foreign
secretary James cleverley and other
politicians on a trip to London his
visit has part of a wider World Tour is
seen as an attempt to show his foreign
policy credentials ahead of a formal bid
for the Republican Presidential
nomination
now we've become all too familiar with
stories of wildfires and drought in
California but now there are weather
problems on the opposite end of the
scale the U.S state has been
experiencing record snowfall over the
winter which has become snowpack in the
mountains and it's now starting to melt
threatening severe flooding our U.S
correspondent Martha Kellner went to one
town to see the impact
Mammoth Lakes is a town entombed by a
snowpack three times the historical
average
in the space of several months
California has swung from severe drought
to extreme winter storms
this is what that looks like in the
mountains everything here is buried
for the skiers and snowboarders it's a
boon
that the locals it's a slow-motion
disaster I just um collapsed it wasn't
even an explosion barely a house here is
undamaged
Steve's own home has become an igloo of
sorts we just now got sunlight in here
it's so heartbreaking many many
countless homes are going to take on
water over
um you know months it's like being
squeezed by an anaconda
and we kept screaming help us um nobody
cut the damn head off
people here no this is a
qatars the worst is likely yeah yeah
come
because these walls with the rising
temperatures are starting to melt
and they're sending tolerance of water
Downstream
the snow-capped mountains are a Spectra
of Doom in California's Central Valley
mere record rainfall has already seen
The Rebirth of Tulare Lake for the first
time in decades this was dry land
beneath the waves Acres of farmland
Tulare Lake hasn't just been resurrected
it's reappeared with a Vengeance it now
covers 30 square miles resembling a vast
Inland sea and over the next couple of
months this could grow to 200 square
miles
this is now a disaster Zone and the
state's Governor is under pressure to
shore up defenses there's not a climate
expert you know there's not a
meteorologist that doesn't say the
following we've never seen this at this
level of intensity in extreme do you
wonder what has to
climate change I just uh visit
California
is emerging from a decade of drought to
different extreme weather the golden
state has now become the southern state
with even more water on the way and for
people here that is a terrifying
Prospect Martha Kellner Sky News
California's Central Valley
now it's technology which could help
people save money and also cut carbon
emissions an eye in the sky which can
detect how energy efficient your home is
a British company is preparing to launch
a satellite which can measure heat loss
from any building but before that the
technique is being deployed in the air
as our science correspondent Thomas
Moore reports we're approaching the
survey site right now we are flying at 8
000 feet above ground in the Skies over
Leeds scientists are mapping Britain's
energy inefficient houses with a flying
thermometer
all we see are lights in the darkness
but with a thermal camera fixed to an
aircraft they can spot heat escaping
from buildings we'll gain insight into
how people are using their energy the
you know they're being impacted by
energy crisis uh things that are
happening at the moment the cost of
energy and uh you know some people are
unfortunately not able to turn on their
heating as much and we may be able to
see variations in temperatures from
building to building the clues are in
the shades of blue the lighter the color
the more heat is being lost and in the
first flight of its kind it takes the
British company's satellite view just
two hours to map a whole city
the average UK home loses heat three
times faster than a house in Germany
drafty Windows uninsulated roofs and
walls relief energy is a massive problem
29 million properties in the UK need
retrofits to make them fit for the
future the MCS charitable Foundation
funded the aerial survey for the city
council it hopes Stark images will nudge
people into taking action I mean we know
these houses are leaky and we know that
we need to solve that problem we need to
be retrofitting
properties that are at a much much
greater rate than we currently are and
the benefit of this technology is that
it helps us pinpoint all local
authorities in particular to pinpoint
where they really need to channel their
efforts to make the most impact
in North Leeds Jonathan knows all about
the quirks of living in a Victorian
Terrace and we sometimes keep the keys
in just to keep the draft out because
you can feel the air coming through here
all up and down here
the images show he's wasting energy and
money insulation just hasn't been a
priority sometimes your money's got to
go somewhere else you know changing
Windows changing doors isn't that
um
keep and sometimes it's something about
getting food on the table it's about all
the other things it's game changing and
now satellite view is about to put its
technology in space from orbiting
satellites they'll be able to measure
heat emissions from any building
anywhere in the world several times a
day giving strategic Clues to activity
in factories and power stations as well
as helping to keep down energy bills
Thomas More Sky News in Leeds
finally tonight this time next week the
coronation will be just hours away and
Buckingham Palace has released new
official photos of the king and queen
consort for the occasion we've also been
given a glimpse of what's known as the
anointing screen which will hide the
king from view at a key point in the
service Dan Whitehead has more
Prince Charles was now in the ABIA to
witness the anointing
it is the most sacred part of a royal
coronation the anointing historically
regarded as a moment between Sovereign
and God
is hidden from cameras and the millions
watching worldwide
70 years on from his mother's coronation
the anointing screen for King Charles
has been completed it will shield the
king as the Archbishop of Canterbury
anoints the sovereign created by 150
students and staff at the Royal School
of needlework the tree design was
personally selected by the Monarch each
Leaf depicting one of the 56 countries
of the Commonwealth it's been incredible
it's been a really really big team
project and I think that's what's been
so lovely about it because everybody has
been able to bring their skills to this
this screen and it's just been amazing
to work with everybody and collaborate
accept our offering of this anointing
screen which we dedicate this day
blessed at a special service at the
chapel Royal at James's Palace the
screen will be carried by service
Personnel from regiments of the
household division before the crowning
of his majesty the screen is there to
actually provide privacy to the most
sacred part of of the ceremony and
previously it was a canopy over the top
which actually didn't provide real
privacy it was more figurative and now
this three-sided screen provides you
know absolute privacy during the process
ahead of next weekend three new
photographs of the king and the queen
consort have been released taken in the
blue drawing room at Buckingham Palace
it is now down to the fine details and
finishing touches with just days to go
till the ceremony he has waited more
than 70 years for now why said Sky News